I think of what happened yesterday or
just recently on fit with Facebook where
they've you know developed a way to
capitalize on the fact that people are
sharing information with you know 50
million people and other people who are
of a like mind and they're going to
attach at you know advertising to these
messages and I think you have to be
really careful that the advertising
doesn't become so intrusive that and it
it's greeted in a hostile environment I
remember many years ago like the 10 or
15 years ago there was an idea and to
put advertising on the on the on the
runways where the baggage was being the
baggage runways and airports so that
while you were standing there wondering
if your baggage was actually going to
come through the door you could be
looking at advertising on the on the
rubber on the rubber strips and I don't
know if that was ever done I don't know
that somehow some airports may have
actually done that and that was an
interesting idea to try and sell
somebody something while they were bored
or terrified that their luggage wasn't
going to show up I don't know that that
was ever done in great numbers i
certainly don't remember seeing it in
the travels I've done but you have to be
careful when you surround the consumer
with advertising messaging that you
don't irritate them in the process and
that means that you have to be
entertaining you have to make them you
have to be appealing you have to make
them want to watch what you're saying
your messaging you have to be a
craftsman so a lot of the user-generated
advertising might be interesting now and
I think it's fun to think about it and
some of it is actually pretty good I
think it's still an art form advertising
and the creative end of advertising
still needs our artists and craftsmen
and people who are good at storytelling
and creating imagery and making things
beautiful and interesting to watch so I
don't know that the user-generated
commercials are going to take over there
it's kind of interesting now I like them
I think it's fun but there's always it's
like a mosaic you know there's a place
for everything
you